Remember Harry Potter?
"Rictusempra!"
~*magic*~
No, no, not that Harry Potter.
I'm talking about the Harry Potter that navigated through the world of wizards and witches to save his family.
(intense music)
*Dementor noises* and ~*magic*~
(Dementor screeches)
No, not that harry Potter
I'm talking about Harry Potter jr.
JUNIOR from Troll! Yes, of COURSE!
junior from Troll yes, of course
Yes, Harry Potter Jr.! Don't you remember? From the 1986 movie Troll?
Ohhhhhhh
It's my favorite Harry Potter Jr.. *giggle* The best thing I've heard in years
Has happened someone made the character Harry Potter junior 15?
years
before
the Harry Potter series from
J.K. Rowling
plagiarized the Harry Potter Jr. character played by Noah Hathaway in the Troll movie.
MY FAVOURITE
series of all time and I CAN'T BELIEVE more people are not talking about this
I am so disappointed in J.K.. My favorite anime character of all time for not... for disrespecting
copyright law.
Now the creator of troll has decided to make
another movie because technically they own their right to the name Harry Potter Jr.
By copyright law they were first!  The movie is going to be called
By copyright law they were first the movie is going to be called troll
Troll: The Rise of Harry Potter Jr.
The rise of Harry Potter Jr.
And I for once can't wait to see the real harry potter in action again
Thank God now Warner Brothers have replied
Now Warner Brothers have replied
They made a statement about this the coming of this film:  "We will vigorously
defend our intellectual property rights and
challenge any unlawful attempt to capitalize on the extraordinary success of the Harry Porry franchise
As we told filmmakers years ago"
Can you taste the salt? I feel like it's coming through the screen.
I haven't seen Troll. "Harry potter Jr., expected to have a little trouble getting adjusted in his new neighborhood
Troll!"
Y-you know I think I'm going to pass. The movie
I have seen however which I actually don't know if it has any correlation to this movie
is Troll 2.
Just so we can get excited for the new Troll movie the rise of Harry Potter, Jr.
What a troll by the way, let's go through Troll 2 and see what we can expect.
"Who are they Grandpa"
-"Cruel,
- "Cruel,
deformed forest dwellers
party creatures
spiteful and impident
Y'know, they're vengeful and evil goblins.. "
he... so it starts off with a
uh..a...a
granddad telling a story to
his...his grandson, but he doesn't call them trolls. He calls them anything but trolls.
his grandson eh, but he doesn't call them trolls he calls them anything but trolls
-"cruel
- "Cruel deformed forest dwellers"
Just call them trolls. Please!
-"vengeful and evil goblins."
- What do you mean Goblins!??
"That's the point.
Goblins don't need to justify their cruel acts"
Goblins don't need to Justify their cruel acts alright, it's it's right movie ?
Hold on, is  this the right movie!?
This- this nibba's talkin' about Goblins!
This neighbors talking about Goblins. Oh
Oh, oh, it's Troll 2. OK, I thought I was watching Goblin 2 for a minute.
Hueah, that's a terrible film, don't wanna watch that shit
No one watch that shit
[Crazy music]
"Goblin!?"
a goblin ?
Acting 101 right there.
acting 101 right there, oh
[grins weirdly]
"A goblin!?"
So basically, ah the family decides to go on a summer holiday
Everything is lovely,
everything is nice.
The good old American
landscape.
Meanwhile on the way, Grandpa's trying to give hints.
"You have to make them go back."
Grandpa is dead by now.
But he's still leaving hints for you to leave
"And we have 30 seconds to come up with some way to stop them."
-Oh wow, I swear time froze there!
-Oh wow they're not just ho- hueahe look you see her shake and everything. [chuckles]  could they not have redone that take?
[squeaky voice] Well where did granddad go? Where did he go?
Nibba you had 30 seconds listen to your granddad!
They're gonna eat the troll goo! You look like you're about to molest your family dude. What are you-
What is he gonna go!?
Did he jus-
Did that- did that nibba just pee on his family?
All right see this guy in blue. Best fucking character in the movie
His acting you may have even seen before
Because it's so good its world-renowned
- "I'll take care of him"
So he saves this lady from the trolls. Sorry goblins!
There's one of them that looks super freaky. I don't know which one it is.
THERE IT IS!! Oh my God what?
Let me give you some advice to to you dwarfs
Oh shit, goblins doesn't like to be called dwarfs.
- " you're going to be in a lot of trouble."
[awkward italian sign]
got'em hueahea oh
shit
"and remember-" [grooowls]
always wear a condom
[bad actor's scream]
[impressed clap]
Alright, so they run into a church
"This is my house!"
But it's the house of a witch and this is where the bluegle -the ah- blue shirt guy. He's acting really shined
"I can't, I can't move, why!? "
- "You talk too much for me!"
[bad acting, on point]
[continuous bad acting]
*just die already*
[forever screaming]
"My God, what's happening to her?"
I can't move,  I cannot move!
Why? ehehe
Oh my God
What is happening to her?
"and why can't I move? There must be a logical reason for all of this!"
and why can't I move? ehehe must be a logical reason to this?
They come to eat her
"They're eating her!!" and then follows the famous. Oh, so beautiful line Oscar-worthy:
"They're eating her!
And they're going to eat me!"
Oh my GooooOOooOOOOOOOODD!
Oh my GOOOOOOOOOOOOOD
No
Best film.
"I don't like this place not one bit!"
Yeah, I could only pee on my family once it wasn't that great even
R. Kelly made it like way better than it is.
- "Oh and sheriff, where do the girls from around here go at night?"
- "AHAHAHA! The girls!?"
Also notice that the town is called Nilbog which I think it's a nice little touch because
Listen to this: [whispers] Nilbog backwards
is GOBLIN! Oh my God. How did we not see that?
Oh my GoOOOOOd he became a PLANT! I don't believe it. This is incredible!
And now the genius child discovers the secret.
- "Grandpa, Grandpa Sam! Are you there?"
Nilbog is goblin backwards...
- "Nilbog is goblin spelled backwards!?"
NILBOG!
- "This is their kingdom!!"
Ahhh hell nah, it's their kingdom!
Yeah, you can probably recover from that. I don't see a problem
"What's wrong why did you stop?"
- "When the time comes, you light the wick and throw the bottle. I'll create some confusion with this."
Wait, how is-how is he alive now? I don't get it
What
Troll also has the best sex scene of all time
undisputable, better than the Room. So the witch eh became eh he h
attractive now.
And she swoozes her way to one of the men, but for some reason-
"What we have to do is.. heat it up"
There's corn in this scene! I don't-
I don't know about the whole corn thing to be honest
I'm pretty sure they're just throwing popcorn at them!
[Felix, "eating popcorn" can be a slang for having sex]
[just look up "eating popcorn meaning"]
What the fuck was that!? This guy looks-
This like, guy looks like a nice guy if I ever see someone come up to me with a smile like that I'd be boi-
- "Can I help you?"
- boi please please help me with anything you want
"Can I help you?"
- "Coffee"
yeah, he really looks like he could use some coffee. This is me when I want coffee. Heahe!!
- "There's no coffee here in Nilbog. It's the Devil's drink!!"
- "Eggs"
I guess I'll go for the second-best then if he doesn't have any coffee. How about some eggs, please!!!
I could really use some eggs
- "Bacon"
How about some bacon then!    - "We're vegetarians here in Nilbog!"
I'm not going to show the end cause I don't wanna spoil the entire movie
I think you guys ah- if you haven't seen it. It's a great movie to watch with some friends
I'm sure there's a drinking game for it as well, and now of course more than anything you feel the hype
the strong hype for Troll: the Rise of Harry Potter Jr
I can't wait! It's going to be the greatest movie of all time and
finally we get to see Harry Potter for what he really is! And none of this bullshit fucking whatever his name is okay
You know what? I don't know what JK Rowling has to say about this
She hasn't really made a statement yet, but I weigh what I imagine her first reaction to be:
"OH MY GOOOOOOOOOOOOD!"
Leave a like if you enjoyed this video, and thank you guys so much for watching!
LET me know if you're excited for Harry Potter Jr: the Rise of the Goblin
give whatever the fuck it's called.
Tweet this video to JK Rowling!
and as always
Sister Fister